have you seen those viral Tick Tock
videos of Jen's ears putting dollar
bills into envelopes it's called Cash
stuffing and it's making cash cool again
the theory is that setting aside
physical currency for each category in
your budget makes it much less likely
that you'll overspend there have even
been studies showing that spending cash
activates the pain centers in our brain
in a way that's swiping a credit card
doesn't credit is theoretical charging
something is mentally easy but cash is
my my own
there's also kind of an ASMR vibe to
many of these videos which makes sense
in a way
from credit cards to crypto money has
been getting more and more imaginary and
it's almost like people are yearning for
it to be tangible again something they
can see feel and hear
of course paper money is still
technically imaginary but that's a whole
other story